[Music]
it came to pass in the year of Christ
1260 when Baldwin was raining at
Constantinople at Messer Nicholas polo
the father of my lord mark and Messer
Maffeo polo the brother of messin
Achilles were at that said city of
Constantinople whither they had gone
from Venice with their merchants where's
now these two brethren men singularly
noble wise and Provident took counsel
together to cross the greater sea on a
venture of trade so they laid in a store
of jewels and set forth from
Constantinople crossing the sea to
saltier
[Music]
having stayed a while at Seoul dear they
considered the matter and thought it
well to extend their journey further so
they set forth from Seoul dia and
traveled till they came to the court of
a certain tartar Prince Barca con by
name whose residences were at Zara and
at bol Gaara and who was esteemed one of
the most liberal and courteous Prince's
that ever was amongst the Tartars this
Barker was delighted at the arrival of
the two brothers and treated them there
with great honour
so they presented to him the whole of
the jewels that they had brought with
them the prince was highly pleased with
these and accepted the offering most
graciously causing the brothers to
receive at least twice its value after
they had spent a twelvemonth at the
court of this Prince they broke out a
great war between Barker and allow the
Lord of the Tartars of the Levant and
great hosts were mustered on either side
but in the end Barker the Lord of the
Tartars of the ponent was defeated
though on both sides there was great
slaughter and by reason of this war
no one could travel without peril of
being taken thus it was at least on the
road by which the brothers had come
though there was no obstacle to their
traveling forward so the brothers
finding they could not retrace their
steps determined to go forward
[Music]
quitting Bulgaria therefore they
proceeded to a city named Oaxaca which
was at the extremity of the kingdom of
the Lord of the potent and thence
departing again and passing the great
river tigris they traveled across a
desert which extended for 17 days
journey and wherein they found neither
town nor village falling in only with
the tents of Tartars occupied with their
cattle at pasture
after they had passed the desert they
arrived at a very great and noble city
noon to Pokhara the territory of which
belongs to a king whose name was Barack
and is also called Baqarah
the city is the best in all of Persia
and when they had got thither they found
they could neither proceed further
forward nor yet turned back again
wherefore they abode in that city of
acara
for three years and whilst they were so
joining in that city there came from
allow Lord of the Levant envoys on their
way to the court of the Great Khan the
Lord of all the Tatars in the world and
when the end voice held the two brothers
they were amazed for they had never
before seen Athens in that part of the
world and they said to the brothers
gentlemen if you will take our counsel
ye will find great honour and profit
shall come thereof so they replied that
they would be right glad to learn how in
truth said the end voice the Great Khan
have never seen any Latins and he hath a
great desire to do so wherefore if ye
will keep us company to his court he may
depend upon it that he will be right
glad to see you and will treat you with
great honor and liberality whilst in our
company ye shall travel with perfect
security and need fear to be molested by
nobody
[Music]
you